um I don't know why that would be I
think it's probably not particularly i'm
trying to think is that is that true i
produce some very good work at at at new
york magazine and if they say that is
probably because i produced more work at
new york magazine so i was writing a
column every week at New York at Vanity
Fair I write a column once a month but I
rather think that I'm producing my best
work now at Newser where I write a
column every day its bulk is ultimately
the the the real currency in our
profession
I think I probably would have gone
bankrupt as most magazines seemed to be
going I was when when that happened I
actually thought that I was going to be
able to buy new york magazine right up
until the moment I I lost it and so my
feelings afterwards were were deeply
conflicting conflicted I I I Love New
York Magazine it was a place that I felt
particularly at home but I had a feeling
of also of immense relief that this
quixotic enterprise of buying the
magazine would not end up as my terrible
fate
when one of the things about about
having worked at at certain places is
that it becomes very hard after you stop
working at them to continue a
relationship to continue even reading
them so I must confess that I don't read
your magazine anymore it's like a lover
spurned